you're watching the birth of an iceberg
from a mile away there's a faint Rumble
as Antarctica's William glassier first
crumbles then collapses a tower weighing
thousands of tons toppling into the
fjord
then rolling with a torrent of water and
ice falling off its sides
the vibrations trigger further ice falls
left and right the camera barely able to
keep up while a crewmate filmed up on
the bridge of our British Antarctic
Survey ship that was astonishment so
let's say you've got fits with moving
this way the whole front then moved off
to the right and then it just started
another cascade further and further and
further down the glass here at which
point we were already standing around
cementec our way out into into deeper
water because we just really weren't
sure exactly how much more it was going
to collapse but the whole face of the
glassy icy looking at it now there's a
completely different fist that so what
it was two days ago but a few hours
later we venture back in the huge
iceberg is grounded on the seabed
offcuts are still splitting and spinning
the blue ice hardened by the immense
pressure of the Gracia is a serious
hazard to our ship we're still around a
kilometer from the iceberg but this is
as far as the captain dares go and with
good reason we can hear all around us
the crackle of gunfire as the Berg's in
the water shatter and up on the
mountainside the roar of cannon fire as
the glacier moves it's impossible to say
how much ice has been lost but five
square miles of water are now covered in
the debris air bubbles thousands of
years old popping like Rice Krispies as
the ice melts it's rare to see such
significant carving but over the last 20
years the glacier has retreated by
almost a mile a bit you're seeing above
the surf it's the 40 odd meters of
vertical extent of both that's released
but then all the stuff below has also
come up and these these icebergs aren't
just the size of houses their size of of
whole whole blocks of houses and blocks
of flats and yeah it's not insignificant
as well Antarctica has lost three
trillion tons of ice over the last 25
years as the planet has warmed ice
that's rapidly adding to sea levels
around the world
Thomas wore Sky News in borgund Bay
Antarctica